even Chicago Alderman's okay these are
the guys who are kind of like the City
Council they're they're running the
government in Chicago notoriously
left-wing City for a very long time even
they are beginning to realize that this
is not working out terribly well we have
leaked audio of an alderman speaking to
Chicago Mayor Lori Lightfoot saying hey
over the past few weeks it's even
crazier than usual in Chicago our
neighborhoods are burning down and
you're not doing anything about it you
know what Lori Lightfoot had to say to
him no thanks don't care no I want an
answer
I bet you commented on every but I want
an answer
it's not something you ignore this is a
question that I had why is it if you
think we want to focus you think
accusing every we're not ready and we
stood by and let the neighborhood go up
there's nothing intelligent that I can
say to you and maybe you should come on
it was going on stupid thing I've ever
heard I understand you want the pre I
understand that you think that you man
you need to check your this guy it's I
really like this alderman too I mean
they they're they're a little more
polite when they know that the cameras
are on but they're really going at each
other because even this alderman says
wait a second this city which has been
run by Democrats for ever since the
prehistoric times is a trash heap of
crime right this city on a good day has
crazy crime in it right on a good day
more people are being shot and killed in
Chicago over a weekend then any number
of unarmed black men killed by police
and in a whole year right and yet you're
only focusing on this one issue and
you're letting our neighborhoods go up
in flames
and the mayor says yeah I don't care I
don't care because it actually serves
their ends I know there's this hope
among conservatives where we say gosh
these leftist policies are so bad
that hopefully people will just totally
wake up and they'll realize they're
really bad policies and they'll flip
them I don't think that's what's gonna
happen I don't think that's what has
already happened if that were true
Chicago would have woken up by now and
elected Republicans but they aren't
doing that because the chaos and the
violence and the madness actually serves
to reinforce the left-wing control of
the institutions look what's happened in
Seattle Seattle is a left-wing City okay
and yet the riders are getting really
really intense there Seattle is a hotbed
of anti feh you know the the anti
fascist allegedly another term for
communist or anarchist lunatics and
violent lunatics who were going out
terrorizing people the rioters in
Seattle broke into and took over City
Hall take a listen to them so they've
taken over there and they are yelling
this at the mayor liberal mayor you're
about to lose your job one thing that
these guys also chant a lot is this is
what democracy looks like you hear that
this is what democracy looks like a
really dark view is gosh maybe that is
what democracy looks like if so not a
great recommendation of democracy but I
think the more reasonable view is that's
not what democracy looks like democracy
looks like showing up to vote and being
a responsible citizen and taking care of
yourself and trying to live a virtuous
life mobs taking over and trying to
occupy whole territories and throw
people out and tar and feather them
that's not democracy
that's a mob and that kind of unrest is
taken as evidence that the Democrats
should keep controlling things
[Music]
you
[Music]